ciao qual è la cosa più inquinante che
avete fatto oggi che avete fatto questa
macchina
pensateci su un attimo magari si deve
venuti il teatro in macchina magari
avete preso un aereo avete preso
l'ascensore di un palazzo che non è
alimentato con energia rinnovabile
avete messo della lacca nei vostri
capelli non sempre pensiamo chi può
naturalmente e non sempre pensiamo che
una delle cose più inquinanti che
facciamo tutti i giorni almeno tre volte
al giorno
io forse anche qualche volta di più a me
e mangiare la cosa più inquinante che
facciamo tutti i giorni e mangiare fare
scelte alimentari che non sono
sostenibili perché tutti noi sappiamo
che i cambiamenti climatici hanno un
effetto prima di tutto sulla terra
evidentemente sul cibo che mangiamo le
alluvioni le bombe d'acqua la siccità
evidentemente impattano sul sulla terra
sul sistema agroalimentare quindi
sistema agroalimentare e vittima è la
prima vittima dei cambiamenti climatici
quello qui non sempre pensiamo e che il
sistema agroalimentare è anche il primo
carnefice e quindi il secondo settore
che inquina maggiormente a livello
planetario
questo è quello di cui vi parlerò oggi
del rapporto tra cibo clima e
innovazione
il cibo non è soltanto la gente con cui
ci nutriamo quando abbiamo fame
prendiamo la prima cosa la mangiamo il
cibo in realtà è un fortissimo agente di
cambiamento
mangiare è un atto agricolo e un atto di
grande responsabilità sociale ed è anche
un atto di grande
instabilità ambientale e il cibo che ci
connette a noi come individui come
esseri umani ea noi come umanità cioè
non solo i 100 anni bene che vada che
abbiamo tutti a disposizione
su questa terra e l'impatto che
generiamo sul pianeta ma più di 250.000
anni che l'umanità è su questo pianeta
quindi connette noi come individui a noi
come umanità
il cibo è una sorta di porta spazio
temporale è una porta temporale perché
ci racconta la sua storia la storia del
territorio da cui proviene delle mani
che lo hanno prodotto degli agricoltori
del dell'amore che ci hanno messo anche
dei pesticidi qualche volta che ci hanno
messo in più anche dell'acqua che è
stata utilizzata per produrlo e quindi è
un modo per onorare il passato è
chiaramente un'esperienza nel presente
ed è soprattutto uno dei modi più chiari
più evidenti che abbiamo per incidere
sul futuro sul futuro delle nostre nuove
generazioni dei nostri figli dei nostri
nipoti da cui ereditiamo il pianeta su
cui viviamo ea cui almeno dovremmo
restituirlo un po meglio di come lo
abbiamo trovato
la provocazione che vi faccio oggi è
questa noi mangiamo quello che
inquiniamo ed inquiniamo mangiando
pensateci bene
mangiamo ciò che inquiniamo perché è
chiaro che è il settore agroalimentare
come vi dicevo il secondo che inquina di
più pensate che a livello globale
tutti gli aerei tutte le macchine tutti
treni inquinano messi tutti insieme il
40 per cento delle volte in meno di
quanto inquina il settore agrolimentare
più del 25 per cento dei gas serra
vengono prodotti da allevamenti
intensivi
pensate che tutti noi succede a tutti
noi di sprecare cibo
ogni anno sprechiamo più di un miliardo
di tonnellate di cibo queste producono
più di 3 miliardi di tonnellate di gas
serra
stiamo parlando di co2 di metano di
protossido di azoto sono sostanze che
vanno nell'atmosfera terrestre e che
quindi impediscono ai raggi solari di
essere filtrati in maniera equilibrata
questo crea lo sappiamo tutti
un surriscaldamento del pianeta il 70
per cento di questo calore in più va
negli oceani nelle acque che quindi si è
significano tantissimo si surriscaldano
quindi tutto il ciclo di vita dell'acqua
viene completamente sballato
ed è per questo che poi assistiamo le
alluvioni alla siccità come vi dicevo
alle bombe d'acqua che incidono sul
terreno che in realtà ha causato questi
fenomeni per il nostro tramite per il
tramite di noi per come produciamo
trasformiamo commercializziamo spostiamo
da un pianeta all'altro con guida un
paese all'altro
comunichiamo consumiamo sprechiamo il
cibo è questo il legame questi sono i
dati che vi ho raccontato e quindi è
chiaro che con il passare del tempo gli
effetti il cibo come dire e danneggiato
dai cambiamenti climatici e per tutto
quello che vi ho detto ed è previsto che
la produzione agroalimentare a causa dei
cambiamenti climatici diminuirà di
almeno il 20 per cento fino al 2050 ma
entro il 2050 è previsto che la
popolazione mondiale aumenterà fino a 9
miliardi di persone
come possiamo sfamarle ci diranno che
dobbiamo aumentare la produzione
agroalimentare
ma forse basterà smettere di sprecare
tutto questo cibo essere più
responsabile più consapevoli che
mangiare un atto agricolo che mangiare
un atto di responsabilità sociale
che mangiare è un atto di responsabilità
ambientale verso le generazioni future e
soprattutto quello che stiamo facendo
non possiamo vederlo significa che non
lo stiamo facendo lo stiamo facendo
tutti tutti noi
il terzo del cibo prodotto di verità
spazzatura
abbiamo creato un modello agroalimentare
che ormai è rotto e ufficiale non
funziona più c'è qualcosa di
profondamente sbagliato quello che al
momento stiamo facendo stiamo assistendo
a più di 800 milioni di persone che
soffrono di fame pensate 3 milioni di
bambini muoiono di fame ogni anno nel
contempo allo stesso tempo sullo stesso
pianeta più di due miliardi di persone
soffrono di obesità di sovrappeso che è
legato evidentemente sempre al cibo il
cibo cielo dovrebbe prescrivere il
medico per quanto è fondamentale per la
nostra vita per il nostro organismo però
questo è quello che abbiamo creato
finora il 70 per cento dell'acqua
potabile viene utilizzata per irrigare i
campi viene utilizzata per produrre ieri
era la giornata mondiale dell'acqua
avrete letto sentito di questi dati ma
allo stesso tempo ecco un altro
paradosso entro il 2025 metà della
popolazione mondiale rischia di non
avere più accesso ad acqua potabile e
quello che stiamo facendo
mangiando come vi dicevo è previsto che
la popolazione mondiale aumenterà
moltissimo e ci diranno che dobbiamo
produrre ancora di più io vedete tutto
questo è questa sensibilità che ho
sviluppato su questo tema e l'ho messa a
fuoco soprattutto quando ho avuto il
privilegio il grandissimo piacere la
fortuna di conoscere il presidente barak
obama
dietro le quinte dell'evento per cui io
stessa lavoravo hoc organizzato con
l'evento il presidente barak obama ha
parlato a milano a maggio nel 2017
esattamente di questo di cibo di clima e
di innovazione e di quello che possiamo
fare per risolvere questo problema ha
parlato per due ore una delle cose che
mi ha più colpito
e stata questa
c'è una cosa che è la più costosa per
noi per la nostra salute per la salute
del pianeta e questa cosa è non fare
assolutamente niente non fare niente
fingere che il problema non esista
sicuramente la cosa più costosa in
termini anche di soldi quello spreco
alimentare quel miliardo di spreco
alimentare all'anno che produce più di 3
miliardi di gas serra ci costa 750
miliardi di dollari all'anno e
chiaramente assurdo
ciao sono le nostre sono lieto e
orgoglioso di dire che partecipo anch'io
al cavo quando in di claudia saluto gli
aidoru e così ha deciso dopo aver
ascoltato barack obama ho deciso di
approfondire questo argomento sui
cambiamenti climatici di cui non sapevo
assolutamente niente mi sono iscritta ho
mandato la mia domanda per essere
formata dall'ex vice presidente degli
stati uniti d'america e premio nobel per
la pace al gore
ho fatto questa domanda incredibilmente
sono stata ammessa dovevo andare a
pittsburgh però deciso di non andarci vi
sembrerà una cosa strana ma il punto è
che ero entrata così profondamente lì
l'idea che il cambiamento climatico
così come l'innovazione e uno sforzo
collettivo cioè che io da sola
chiunque di noi neanche al gore neanche
barak obama nessuno da solo avrebbe
veramente risolto il problema ma che
richiede come ho detto uno sforzo
collettivo è una cosa che si risolve
solo se la facciamo tutti insieme
se qualcuno imbroglia lombale la
dobbiamo fare effettivamente tutti
insieme che ho deciso di attivare un
crowdfounding
cioè una raccolta di fondi dal basso per
raccogliere i soldi per andare a
formarmi con al gore a pittsburgh il
punto è è disposta alla mia comunità
la mia tribù i miei amici di facebook i
miei colleghi di lavoro a pagare per la
mia formazione non per la loro
formazione è disposta a capire che io mi
sto formando anche per loro e che mi
impegno e garantisco arresti e mi
impegno a restituire questa formazione
anche a loro volevo passare da me a noi
sono queste le due velocità di cui vi
sto parlando
la velocità dell'individuo e la velocità
di noi come comunità è possibile ho
incontrato linus sotto radio deejay che
ha fatto questo video che avete appena
visto
ho anche ricevuto un post su facebook da
parte di giancarlo una persona che io ho
incontrato una volta nella mia vita è
tra l'altro per lavoro mi ha scritto
sulla bacheca di facebook l'ashtag era
larix founding limitiamo la ricca di
cognome mi trovate anche su twitter come
claudia larix mi ha scritto che ci sono
tanti motivi per promuovere la mia
iniziativa il mio crowdfunding però lui
ne aveva tre e sono tommy luca e jacopo
che sono questi bellissimi bambini che
vedete qui sono stata autorizzata da
giancarlo diffondere questa fotografia
in bocca al lupo ritorna piena ed idee
da condividere con i bambini che sono i
nuovi geri al servizio del futuro di
tutti noi
se hai bisogno di tre combattenti che ti
aiutino a diffondere amplificare la
speranza conta pure su tommy luca e
jacopo io non mi sarei mai aspettata
questo riscontro né che in meno di un
mese
io raccogliessi anche da persone che non
conoscevo affatto dei soldi ho capito
che tutti siamo sensibili a questo
argomento
tocca a tutti noi tocca profondamente
tutti noi dobbiamo fare forse uno shift
mentale più sulla diventare anche agenti
di cambiamento nella pratica ce l'ho
fatta ha raccolto questi soldi ho
conosciuto al gore sono diventata
climate
eder faccio parte della sua rete siamo
12.000 in 136 paesi
facciamo parte anche di un hub che una
sorta di social network dove ci
scambiamo informazioni sto studiando sto
cercando di capire un po meglio come
funziona il fenomeno cosa posso fare io
anche stando qui a parlarne con tutti
voi
questi siamo tutti noi
la classe che si è formata a pittsburgh
ho capito quindi che innovazione
cambiamenti climatici sono uno sforzo
collettivo è una cosa che possiamo fare
che funzionerà perché funzionerà questa
è la buona notizia
noi abbiamo il potere oggi mai tanto
forte come oggi di poter cambiare
veramente le cose
perché mai tanto come oggi noi abbiamo
accesso ad una tecnologia straordinaria
lo dice anche bill gates e mai mai come
oggi è stata tanto accessibile anche
tanto economica se volete anche
l'innovazione prima culturale prima
mentale e poi tecnologica ci può aiutare
può aiutare ciascuno di voi tutti noi a
passare da me a noi questa fotografia è
stata scattata dalla nasa nel 1972 per
la prima volta l'uomo si è percepito
come umanità in questa blu marble questa
sfera celeste sospesa nel cielo
nessun confine nessuna barriera
nessuna divisione non prima gli italiani
e non prima gli americani prima gli
esseri umani
questa fotografia avuto un potere visivo
così forte che anche da lì è cominciato
come dire un nuovo movimento
più di recente il on mask ilon masche
che uno degli uomini più ricchi del
pianeta più visionari del pianeta e
quello che ha inventato la tesla space
hicks ha mandato appunto la tesla nello
spazio su marte lo sappiamo tutti
e successo a febbraio 2018 che cosa ha
inciso sulla testa
mandata su marte che sta orbitando
ancora sulle nostre teste fatta sulla
terra da umani cosa c'entra il cibo con
tutto questo è il cibo un unico
linguaggio universale che ci unisce che
ripeto ci fa passare da noi come
individuo a noi come umanità
sappiamo già che questo sistema non è
più sostenibile che innovare lo dice
anche papà francesco è un imperativo
morale allora di che parlo quando parlo
di innovazione nel cibo io oggi come
diceva claudio lavoro per il feature
food institute è un'organizzazione
internazionale no profit leader nella
food innovation nell'innovazione del
cibo con loro
sarò in giro per il mondo faccio il giro
del mondo in 60 giorni dal 12 maggio al
12 luglio con 15 ricercatori del food
innovation programme andiamo in giappone
in thailandia in cina hong kong india
olanda germania spagna stati uniti
canada per incontrare start up aziende
università centri di ricerca innovatori
gli influenzatori giornalisti
consumatori e gente che mangia per
incontrare persone e diffondere questo
messaggio dell'importanza
dell'innovazione quando parlo di
innovazione parlo di acqua tonica di
idroponica di ed di aeroporti ca di
sensoristica in agricoltura di
agricoltura di precisione l'internet
delle cose applicata al cibo di big data
di futuro delle proteine di supermercati
del futuro di cucina intelligente
stampanti 3d che stampano il cibo parlo
di tutto questo con la consapevolezza
che l'innovazione può aiutarci e la
tecnologia può aiutarci a far emettere
meno gas serra elementi nocivi
nell'atmosfera terrestre e quindi ad
aiutare anche il pianeta e le future
generazioni
questo lo stiamo facendo con
l'educazione con la formazione che di
sicuro è l'arma più potente
28 secondi per finire raccontarvi di un
brevissimo reddito che mi è successo a
natale a natale ho passato un pomeriggio
con due bambine sofia e margherita sette
e tre anni le nipoti di donatella
donatella la mia carissima amica a cui
dedico questo discorso perché lei era in
ospedale e oggi purtroppo non c'è più
sono stata con le sue nipotine sufi e
margherita di 73 anni periodo di natale
a che gioco possiamo giocare giochiamo
al presidente della repubblica
facciamo finta che tu sei il presidente
della repubblica scrivimi 10 punti
fondamentali per il bene della nazione
le bambine hanno scritto diritto
all'aria pulita diritto al cibo per
tutti l'inalienabile diritto a stare
comodi che non è pertinente ma anche a
stare comodi mentre salti questo gioco
che ho fatto con loro mi ha insegnato
tre cose fondamentali la prima è che
puoi studiare con al gore conoscere
barak obama andare in giro per il mondo
ma niente così importante di ascoltare i
bambini di ascoltare i giovanissimi che
hanno una percezione della verità più
pulita più autentica la seconda è che
tutto si può fare
si può scrivere a sergio mattarella
questa storia sul forum del sito del
presidente della repubblica a ricevere
questa lettera dove sergio mattarella mi
ringrazia per avermi messo al corrente
di questo gioco con fatto con le bambine
e le abbraccia perché donatella non c'è
più
il terzo punto è ma se non lo facciamo
noi chi
e se non adesso quando grazie